محمد هلال ومحمد الشذري ومحمد امين ثلاثه
اصدقاء من اصل بنغالي ذاهبون رفقه ازواجهم
لاداء فريضه الحج قلق رفقهم خلال عمليه
التسجيل حتى تاكيد حجزهم لخوض هذه الرحله
الايمانيه
كم كنت سعيدا عندما تاكد الذهاب لاعداء
مناسك الحج لاول مره مع زوجتي وهذا من فضل
الله تعالى
بوابه الكترونيه اعتمدتها وزاره الحج
والعمره لتطوير التجربه الرقميه لضيوف
الرحمن من اوروبا وامريكا واستراليا
ونيوزيلندا بدءا من تسجيل عمليه الترشح
والقبول الى اختيار باقه الحج من الشركات
النظاميه ضمن الجهود المبذوله لتسهيل
الاجراءات
محظوظ من يستطيع حج بيت الحرم وسط ازمه
غلاء المعيشه ومحظوظ اكثر على من يحصل على
احد الاماكن المحدوده المخصصه للراغبين في
الحج من بريطانيا هذا العام الحمد لله
انا جدا محظوظ كما تعرف اكثر من 20 الف
شخص يذهبون الى الحج من بريطانيا والعدد
الان تم تقليصه الى قرابه اربعه الاف شخص
انا جدا متحمس ومحظوظ لخوض هذه الرحله
الروحانيه
الكثير تغير وانا متحمس لتجربه هذا النظام
الجديد للحج وانوي اداء مناسك الحج بقدر
المستطاع على افضل وجه
هؤلاء الاصدقاء الثلاثه استكملوا جميع
متطلبات السفر الى مكه والمدينه تلقوا
الارشادات الوقائيه والنصائح اللازمه
اثناء اداء شعائر ومناسك الحج وحزموا
حقائبهم للانضمام الى الحجاج من كافه
انحاء العالم مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات